is the EVP of football operations for
the Jaguars Tom Coughlin's here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you how are you
Tom you good I'm good very good thank
you how you enjoying the front office
well I'm enjoying that part of it I'm
enjoying being you know knee-deep in
football and and when I came you know
obviously the the very next step was
free agency the very next step you know
was the the League meetings and then the
draft and so on and so forth and now
into you know the phase three of the
offseason program on the field observing
every day being a part of that
it is a it's a good thing it's a little
different for me and I'm still adjusting
to that but but working well with Doug
Marrone and Dave Caldwell what's the
biggest adjustment you've had to make
that adjustment is that you know I am
I'm not the head coach
I'm not designing practice schedules I'm
not doing the talking to the team I am
NOT not conducting those exercises that
a head coach conducts and I've done that
for a long time enjoyed those very parts
you know that I'm talking about the
practice schedules the schedules
themselves the offseason the summer the
training camp all of that stuff so
that's a little bit different and as we
move forward it'll be interesting to see
how we do when I get it when we get into
the you know regular season and and then
in terms of the evaluation of the
players that that were already there
what did you see in Blake bortles that
led to the decision to pick up his
option for next year
Tom years ago yeah an outstanding year
he had a lot of yardage over 4,000 yards
I won't say outstanding because the team
didn't do outstanding but you know he he
certainly was much more productive this
past year a lack of production if you
will
turnovers too many and so he's a
talented young man had some flaws in his
throwing motion that
that he did a nice job of working on in
the offseason and pretty much correcting
so we've seen some good things there
well in terms of that though I mean the
the concept of of not letting him play
out this season and maybe using that as
the the carrot at the end of the stick
why go ahead and give him that extra
year when perhaps you're new to the
scene there and might want to go in a
different direction as an EVP and and
tie yourself to him for a second
consecutive year well the old thinking
there's we thought it was a very good
business decision a good decision for
the club a good decision for for Blake
and his team as well but obviously we
have we have very good business people
here and the thought was it was a good
move it's an opportunity for us to keep
alive the various tags of franchise tag
the transition tag to be utilized on
other players if we need it and also the
negotiating point would be from the
option so we thought it was a good move
Tom Coughlin jaguar's EVP joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show who does for
net remind you of you know he is a
powerful built back in such a way that
the outstanding hips and upper legs etc
very very powerful heads as elusiveness
we've seen the speed that we thought we
were going to see on the practice fields
here in the last couple of days so he's
a is his own man and I wouldn't say that
he reminds me to everyone I know we
first took him people said you know is
this a is this a similar pic to Brandon
Jacobs for example well brain it was 265
pounds
Leonard is Lee reported here was a
little bit around 240 and we've got them
down a little bit lower than that we'd
like them to play you know 230 right in
that area but
he is a talented young man who's
dedicated himself to learning this
scheme and is anxious to prove his
ability in the NFL well I mean when when
he was at the combine and sing with
McCaffrey Tom when we were sitting there
in our booth for the NFL Network we were
hearing how that both for net and
McCaffrey were getting peppered with
questions about their dedication to
teamwork and because they didn't play
their full games to try and make sure
they were healthy enough for the draft
how did that question play on your mind
well we had to dig and we brought our
research our due diligence talked to all
the people involved talked to his
position coach there was some things
that happened you know at LSU and
Leonard last year that that were not I
would say putting your best foot forward
the injury the ability to play the way
is capable of playing the decision about
the ballgame but he is a football player
and he's anxious to to have the
opportunity to make an impression on
this week so you didn't have a problem
with him sitting on his Boggan well
whether I did or didn't he certainly
passed the test we talked to a lot of
people and whether I agree with that
disagree with that
whether it's McCaffrey whether it's for
not what I think in that regard is not
the important thing I do think is a
football player Tom Coughlin joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show any contact
at all with anyone in the Giants
organization or if you just put that in
your rearview mirror Tom no the Giants
have been continually just to support
the Jay fund foundation we have what we
call rich our Sunday blitz which John
Merrow Steve pace gave permission for
that to be conducted at MetLife Stadium
where families who have a child with
cancer were entertained for a day they
left cancer in the parking lot they had
all kinds of events and fun and then
finish the day with an ice cream sundae
so the Giants
some of the giant players people that
work in the giant organization were kind
enough to put forth a great effort again
to help these families and put a smile
on the face of these kids and we were
very grateful for that is Eli Manning a
hall-of-famer
in your mind Tom yes you didn't start
there what makes you know what makes you
say that about you I know the inner
workings of the young man I know how he
performs in big games I know what he did
for us in the years that I was a head
coach with the Giants I know what we did
what any of course she believed was the
right choice in terms of of maneuvering
to make sure that that Eli reliant
uniform and you know just like anyone
else
sometimes the some very very Goods and
some of the some games not as good as
others she'd be the first one to talk
about that but overall the quality of
the young man the character the young
man the way in which he works on the
field MVP of two Super Bowls arguably at
least one of the games being one of the
greatest of all time so I don't in my
opinion he certainly was always our
franchise quarterback and worthy of any
accolades that come his way in terms of
what beats inside then who is Odell
Beckham jr. in your estimation tom I I'm
I'm not going there I'm not I'm not with
the Giants anymore and that certainly is
speculated by others and hotels an
extremely talented player how has
Jacksonville changed with you coming
back from when you first started there
well there's only about four people left
to registered we're here when I actually
I hired most of everyone that would that
anything to do a football there's only
probably three or four people that are
left and so the the idea of meeting and
visiting with a whole new organ
in terms of people a new owner in terms
of shotgun a the organization has grown
in numbers of people who are employed
here as is relatively consistent with
what I've seen throughout the National
Football League
they've been some some new faces in
terms of what has been done here the
indoor facility is on the way a very
very nice outdoor facility has been
completed where concerts are held
etcetera mr. Khan has put a lot of
interest in the development of downtown
here in Jacksonville the people of the
great people of greater Jacksonville
continue to do a super job supporting
the Jaguars they deserve a winner and
that's why we're here and and while you
were gone at least they put in that
swimming pool you were pushing for them
to put in right when you first started
right yeah they implement it higher
higher on the wall and I than I asked
for Thanks what do you think of the
celebration rules being relaxed Tom what
do you think of that idea
I don't could be honest with you rich I
I just I get the concern over wanting to
improve the pace of the game and then
loosening up on the celebratory rules
because I know how that went when it
first came about and really I don't I
know there should be a certain amount of
fun and so on and so forth but that's
not what my opinion of the way the game
should be played is or a team sport and
I I hate to think that those guys you
know sitting in front of Rocker scheming
about public we're going to do a
celebrations rather than you know how
we're going to get there in the first
place so you know I've always been a act
like you've been there before kind of a
guy and I think celebrations come when
the game is over coach Tom really
appreciate you joining look forward to
the next time we have a conversation
thank you for calling it's nice to talk
to you as always I find however he can
help with the Jay fund we're all over it
so please let us know thank you
you bet that's Tom Coughlin the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stay
since across the country and audience if
you liked that video be sure to download
our apps don't have any memory on your
phone let's start to delete some of
those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about